hello I'm Lawrence this is my question
to you David gross will will we be able
to live in another galaxy hi Lawrence so
you're asking whether we will be able to
live in another galaxy probably as far
as we can tell galaxies are more or less
all the same there's some differences we
live in a spiral galaxy but there many
many such galaxies throughout the
universe there are 10 billion galaxies
in the visible universe so there are
lots of galaxies where we life like us
could have evolved we believe if we can
live in other places of our galaxy and
we believe more and more that they're
probably millions of planets like ours
throughout the galaxy where life could
have evolved life like ours were just as
likely to or life like ours is just as
likely to evolved in other galaxies but
it's very unlikely that we will ever be
able to physically go to these other
galaxies we can't travel faster than the
speed of light and it would take us even
at those speeds millions of years to go
to other galaxies so it's even hard for
us to imagine communicating with other
galaxies because again light or radio
waves that we would use for such
communication can't go faster than the
speed of light or radio waves and they
would also take millions of years to
reach these other galaxies so it'd be
very hard to have a telephone
conversation if you had to wait over a
million years to get a reply so we're
only going to know rather indirectly our
weather life definitively exists on
other galaxies but it most likely does